souvenez vous il y a tout juste un an le
premier nano satellites d'étude du
climat et est envoyé dans l'espace par
le laboratoire atmosphères observations
spatiales de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
premier satellite qui fournit des
données scientifiques exploitables il va
être rejoint par son petit frère inspire
7,7 dans l'objectif final de créer une
constellation de petits satellites nous
avons mis en oeuvre un deuxième
satellite qui s'appelle inspire sats est
donc son objectif c'est de faire une
étude
du bilan radiatif de la terre donc on va
s'intéresser à l'étude du climat et on
cherche à mesurer des variables
climatiques essentielles le premier
démontre qu'un anneau sat est capable de
donner des données scientifiques utile
mais l'idée c'était de quand même de
voir si une constellation de plusieurs
satellites rajoute pas une plus value
importante en faisant des tendres visite
au dessus d'un même point plus rapide
véritable bijou de technologie il pèse
seulement 3 kg et fait la taille de de
rubik's cube il reste dans le standard
cube sat c'est à dire c'est des carrés
de 10 par dix mais là on a rassemblé 2
carré de 10 par dix vous avez des
cellules solaires sur chaque face
cave cellules solaires ça ça va nous
permettre de générer une puissance
d'environ une dizaine de watts par face
ensuite sur ses droits nous avons des
hommes blanchis sur lesquels vous en
venir fixer nos capteurs nous utilisons
des détecteurs plans pour pouvoir faire
des mesures de flux infrarouge pour
faire nos mesures de déséquilibre
énergétique toute la phase de conception
et de réflexion sur la science a été
fait maintenant on en est à l'assemblage
donc on va voir si moi d'assemblage de
tests avec les outils que l'on a ici à
guyancourt qui permet vraiment de tester
si clash thermique le vide tout ce qui
est nécessaire et puis après il ya tous
les étalonnages pour pouvoir
effectivement livré l'instrument à temps
pour qu'ils embarquent tous les essais
sont effectués sur place au total c'est
une équipe d'une dizaine de chercheurs
qui s'ils occupent quotidiennement le
lancement d'un spears at 7 est prévue en
début 2023